the lcs is having a meltdown a possibly
huge change to pro league of legends in
north america
has everyone at each other's throats
they might be getting rid of the
import rule and as a result owners of
two of the biggest
orgs in the world have been fighting
with fans
and players on social media it's an
absolute
[ __ ] show and we're gonna dive right
into it
[Music]
all right this is a big story and well
done for not missing it but if you want
to make sure
you also never miss a big story in the
future
make sure you are subscribed if you
haven't done so already
all right we are gonna get to the owners
fighting with fans and players
c9's owner accused a random redditer
of racism while tsm's owner implied that
an lcs player would be working minimum
wage without the league
trust me we're gonna get there but to
understand how we got here we have to go
back
and talk about the lcs import rule and
how it came to be
when the lcs was formed back in 2012 the
rules for
importing players from other regions was
pretty simple
there were none it was the wild west if
a team of foreign players
wanted to play in the lcs they could and
that's exactly
what an all-star chinese team called lmq
did
when they gigger stomped the lcs in
2014. they even represented
na at worlds that year despite being an
entirely
chinese org and team many were worried
that if this kept happening it would
squeeze out
local n a talent for good now really
quickly if you guys don't already know
league of legends is broken up by
different regions
traditionally china and korea have been
really really dominant on the
international stage and north america
has
has not they suck riot responded to the
whole lmq situation by introducing their
inter-regional
movement policy moving forward teams
would only be allowed
two non-residents on their team and
residency could be achieved after
playing in north america for
two years this policy would keep teams
in each region
as an actual representation of that
region
and not just a bunch of bought talent
two years later in 2016
riot changed the rules again they kept
the two
non-resident limit per team but change
the time
played to gain residency from two years
to four years
and they have to obtain some sort of
legal permanent residence such as
citizenship
that's how things are right now but it
looks like it could
all change again and by change
i mean ripping up the entire import
rulebook forever
as travis gafford first reported in
february
some amount i don't know if it's all of
them or some of them
but some of the lcs teams are pushing
riot
to remove the import restriction for the
lcs
the idea being that you can import as
many players as you want so you could do
the full
korean team and all that stuff back in
the day this could
change everything no import restrictions
could mean no incentive to search for
local talent
if a team has cash to splash they could
fill their roster
with the best foreign talent money can
buy if this were to happen
you could technically get the north
american
championship having zero north american
players
in it what and if that happens it could
wash away the home-grown
talent development system that was
really only
just beginning to find its feet people
had
questions but when travis pushed the
owners for clarity on the matter
some of them kept hit real vague but one
owner stood out as pretty damn clear
about wanting the change
it sounds like you'd like to see it
lifted entirely yeah
i don't see a point for it i'm i uh
you know cloud9 has teams all over the
globe
um in korea in europe like everywhere
and i like to support
young people no matter where they're
born and i don't really like
putting up these kind of artificial
fences to inhibit that development
that was c9 owner jack there showing
support for the rule
being lifted now whether or not you
agree with his answer
it was a pretty reasonable answer right
well he got pretty
unreasonable on reddit recently and this
is where this whole story
just takes a hard right to crazy town so
there was a thread on the c9 subreddit
discussing all of this
a user by the name of keymoin25
said cloud9 might be an international
team but nalcs is in north america for
north american players
you are representing north america for
north
american fans we want to see our players
in the lcs
not a bunch of koreans and c9 jack
replied with i don't agree with your
opinion and that's fine
your comment not a bunch of koreans he's
distasteful
and would be considered racist by many i
don't support xenophobic or racist
comments and would like to see us
elevate beyond that type of sentiment
the whole thing just blew up from there
people
poured into the thread as the discussion
deteriorated into jack just
spatting with random redditors saying
they were being
insensitive that they're putting quotes
in his mouth and that they need to check
their sources
and if you thought tsm was gonna let c9
hog the spotlight here well you thought
wrong
tsm's owner reginald weighed into the
whole discussion
with his own poorly judged social media
post c9 vulcan suggested that if the lcs
owners want a team of foreign talent
they should just buy a team in another
region reggie replied saying
ignorant tweet if every lcs team left
the lcs
you'd be out of a job buddy and probably
be
paid minimum okay then as you might
expect
this did not go down well with the
community cheetou ocelot said this is
one dumb [ __ ] take
vulcan asked for clarification on
whether that meant he'd be working at
mcdonald's
team liquid's core jj was inspired by
that and suggested a one-off game
between
team imports and team mcdonald's
doublelift memed reggie by using the
still fresh jack comment as a template
captain flowers poked fun at tsm's
world's performance by simply saying
this tweet went owen six and pretty soon
the whole [ __ ] show had developed into
reggie just spamming the word
imports over and over again
at this point it's like what the [ __ ] is
going on
what the [ __ ] is next well despite
enough discussions and
petty arguments to fill up the league's
subreddit for the past month
the answer is we just don't know yet
this whole thing
revolves around a discussion that is
being had between
riot games and the lcs owners behind
closed doors on the one hand you've got
the argument for
removing the import rule now whether or
not you agree
that that's a good idea you should at
least hear what the orgs have to say
i thought tsm's manager path did a good
job of explaining
that side of things when he spoke to
travis about how
north america is at a disadvantage with
the current system
ultimately it doesn't matter how much we
invest into coaching or infrastructure
and facilities and performance programs
if we don't have
access to the same number of talent as
other regions
other major regions so we do see some
sort of changes in the import rule to
help us even the playing field a bit
for them it makes business sense if you
have the money
and you want to push your brand out
there into the world you're going to
want to hire the best talent you can
for them they're not just competing with
the teams that are geographically
close they're competing with teams and
their brands
all over the world and they feel like
some of those teams have advantages
based on their geographical location
or server size which makes the import
rule unfair
alright but what about the other side
well for every lcs
owner pushing for this there's plenty of
people
pushing back immortals revenge and n a
native
said that no org owner can convince me
to my
face that if the import rule was removed
this last offseason
i would have been given a chance in the
lcs azalea made an impassioned plea to
let the amateur scene grow in the lcs
stating that it feels like the exact
wrong time to remove
import restrictions team liquid santorin
one of the longest standing
lcs imports tweeted out some thoughts on
the matter
saying the reason why i do like the
current import rules is the fact that
you cannot just straight up take another
team
from another region and put the entire
roster into north america
and consider it an n a team right now
you have to compete in
n a for several years before actually
being considered
an n a resident at this point you have
shown that you want to play
under n a and represent them and you've
probably built up a fan base in america
and kind of been established into the
scene and he finished things off by
saying
if ultimately it came down to it i would
prefer losing my
n a residency over seeing the import
rule
get removed completely so what's the
answer here
well this isn't the first time the whole
imports discussion
has come up but it certainly feels like
the most intense
and that might be because an answer
feels like it's
just around the corner we just have to
wait to hear the outcome of these
shadowy talks between riot and the lcs
owners
will riot cave in and revert to the open
system that they themselves once said
was
hurting the growth of local talent will
na
end up with another lmq on its hands a
north american team with
no north american players speaking of
lmq
they actually knocked out curse to earn
that final
ticket to worlds 2014. one of those
curse members
was voyboy now he tweeted out a video
this past week which
really summed up the whole situation for
me any lsts teams have suddenly no need
to even field any n8 players what's to
stop and you know
another full five-man roster from korea
or
china or eu just to come in and take up
an nalcs spot
and you know that's in my opinion it
doesn't really feel like you know a
north american league and if you
remember
when all these global regions and the
leagues were made by riot they made lcs
they made you know lac eu lcs
lck lpl the minor in major regions
the point of all these regional leagues
was to showcase
the native talent just let me know in
the comments if you agree with him and
also what the best way forward is here
for the lcs you you just got
um your permanent status residency
right for canada i did yeah so i'm
hoping to become a
become a player what was that you're
gonna be a league player now right yeah
yeah on my list of like ways to become
pro league player it was
i had to get permanent residency uh and
and be challenger and the challenge the
coming challenge is way easier so i
thought i'd leave that till last
um yeah i'll just become a top 10 player
after this so i'm ready now so next week
i'll be in the top 10
in league and you can expect to see me
being reported on on this channel
oh you know what i love about riot and
they have done a lot of like
path clearing i think in esports in
terms of like setting standards
but they but they're so self-aware about
that that they named they named things
the inter-regional movement policy like
it's
it's a so there's an error about it that
is so sort of
but they were they they were then
referencing it as the imp
it's now come on uh yeah the imp was
locked in place in 2016. it's like
you're not the fbi what the hell
he's broken my imp god damn it
that was it
[Laughter]
my favorite friend